welcome to this video playing double yah
what is this
it is a vein yeah yeah I suspected that
it's funny I call yourself w from
albania and menthol she's not even
playing it's got some some very friendly
dialogue in his in his profile okay and
he is still not playing a move let's see
not going to sing okay so in five him
keep it solid within bounce that I
actually know yeah I have experimented a
bit with them with come on with the
Sicilian Kalashnikov but I didn't really
feel that well not really because
because of the opening it's just that I
didn't I don't know the the the theory
them and it got me to trouble quite
often so I'm getting back to my tried
and tested if I've move yeah the good ol
word and notice it's really true vegan
again trying to like do don't you want
to exchange them seems he doesn't how do
I go here maybe gee maybe this no Bishop
g5 moves
9300 M hmm not sure if it was a great
idea okay taking them Knights e5 e6
would be a good way to position things
it's not not so easy for him to get an F
for him with them pawn structure as it
is a for the kind of risky movement I go
here at Bishop h6 so I have to do this
yeah a form yeah as I said it's a risky
move but he nevertheless played it okay
let's take here first maybe not sure
start with that I don't know
[Music]
yeah now he has this somewhat weak ish
upon but he has active pieces definitely
so it's not that he's in trouble or
anything okay let's get get out of a
possible check them and turn really okay
[Music]
it surprised me a bit but it's not bad
[Music]
hope you've won yeah I should have
thought about that move it's not exactly
rocket science
[Applause]
it takes a trip ti-84 queen III that's
actually quite okay no Queen d6 is not a
problem at all I can play up the eight
that's quite okay and maybe you can play
c5 but it's no way back here anyway
c5 yeah that that is a move just six I
can go look before allowing this book
the eight business
I could rotate queen d8 business they're
not sure if this how good that is for
wine actually because I am my queen is
secretly active Queen can go here and
attack he has got some foreign
weaknesses and my knight only five is
obviously quite nice so this is this is
kind of ok from it for me I think he for
CC to they were there all week
I came it's covering that once I'm going
to take him still a taxi to rookie to
Queenie three years is a nice little
thing to happen maybe don't see how he
defends see to really
[Music]
ya can check see - now he has got rookie
7 though
and night 96 of the passive move I don't
like that one really don't
mmm that's not good not good at all
I cannot I cannot really I can maybe
take see two rookies seven Queeny to
check on v6 King h8 Rock g1 yeah okay I
don't want to do a passive passive
defense it's not a good idea I don't
think so so let's do that
so Luke g7 King age eight rook g1 I mean
where is he going
probably has to go rook g1 no time
warning
[Music]
playing against rook F to possibly
Knight f4 at the right moment at the
moment that's not on of course but maybe
I get in Queen d2 Knight f4 this this
kind of thing it's still not taking some
check somehow can always give a ton of
checks
maybe look f3 here Wow
but neither force is really possible I
spinning me
now I was a very good move for up to
seven very good move
awkward Luke f3 was also strong check
check
[Music]
check check check check check check
check check check check check check
[Music]
check check
[Music]
white for fits on time that would have
been heartbreaking to use this at the
end he was super quick I mean I was
hugely down on time but he was super
quick here aid against three I mean he's
spending simply no time that's what no
okay yeah I'd rather wasn't it was a
kind of rollercoaster game and he writes
to me Punk
okay that's not that's not enough to
report him but I will report everybody
was insulting okay I'm okay here
definitely but nothing nothing great I'm
I really relied on that but he can take
it's really true champion and that's in
very interesting position here and I
probably I don't know I took it he went
here and from here
but what a [ __ ] you okay so f6 9 m5
Quincy 207 that's kind of okay I think
here it's difficult to play really as
difficult to claim check
could have taken with the night but this
is this is very dangerous also rook g6
is strong I thought that was difficult
to play rook d7 was strong yeah I didn't
see that move check check
[Music]
here we have six wins 30 check if that
material check check check
and then then blundered the pawns one by
one
yeah that wasn't a good game really I
should have probably should improve
somewhere here yeah I'm okay but I
didn't didn't play well the structure is
quite okay here for black the d6 bonus
is a bit bit iffy but he also has some
weaknesses in his structure
I actually thought that this would be
okay but okay this Queen Queen d6 this
transformation wasn't um wasn't very
favorable I guess okay thanks for
watching